i'm yuki and i work as the science
content manager i work on the videos
exercises and articles in our sciences
so biology chemistry and physics
failure is growth
i think is a motto i've seen upstairs
but yeah for me growth mindset is really
all about like embracing failure and
embracing
um
just trying things even when you know
it's not gonna work the first time and
it might not even work the second time
but you just keep trying and you might
try adapt a little bit until you feel
like you've really got it because
you can you can do anything i an example
i might give is in chemistry so that's
where my background is and that's
arguably my expertise it is my expertise
but um i wouldn't say that's something
that necessarily came that easily to me
um i think it took me a really long time
to develop good study habits and one
thing that was really hard for me from
the beginning was like
speaking up when i needed help and so i
i learned pretty late in college that um
if i didn't get something
it really like
even though i might feel like i was
gonna look dumb like getting like
letting a teacher or a teenager right
away that hey i don't get this can you
explain this to me again
um very quickly was important so going
to office hours really being super vocal
about when i don't know something so i
could get help as soon as possible and
then also
um
the other thing i figured out was the
more practice i do on something the
better i'll get at it so even if i think
i know something if i can't actually
show that on paper that doesn't mean
anything so trying to like also get lots
of repetition in on things that i'm not
that confident about
to really highlight when i don't know
things was something i learned very late
in college but was super helpful to me
once i figured that out not just in
chemistry but in general